hey what if discovery kills hey Brian
Brennan wanted to find the kid right and
Harris out what it's called finding kid
wild and so ring give Brian five million
Brennan five million and we take you all
around the world and you got a get bit
by the worst [ __ ] insects in the
world and snakes five mil five million
in a - a year - no it's just one season
one season 12 episodes yeah what
something we have to do it five melted
five mil in in this coronavirus
situation I pay off my houses as I'm
vulnerable
and I don't want to be stressed out
right now yeah I'll take some steaks I
gotta get stung by some bad [ __ ] though
the worse the worse coyote Peterson the
executive you hate to do this what you
know if you get it you dead what I'm not
any hate risk ah you are though you are
your percentage is so much higher than
when I say on my last on my on my on my
deathbed I thought no this is you on
your deathbed ready you just going you
the one what I owe them say he's you see
son my wife they're talking about it yes
and I got like no no please don't
confuse him for the woman I come back
tonight no you you big [ __ ] fish just
keep on that I'm like everybody gather
around but I would say something wrong
your ass is built for power not for
[ __ ] though I have a nice for us any
last wishes Brian ask me again Ryan are
you okay you have any what yeah what
yeah you look all old and sick
your ass is gone gasps felt a spell I
clean my whistle Oh
your skin's yellow like mr. burns Oh
grab my wish you [ __ ] off well that was
kind of a darkish [ __ ] sorry guys
oh sorry everybody sorry about my
[ __ ] comment it's [ __ ] this Monday
and if you can't laugh go [ __ ] yourself
I am done needed putting that much you
need to send us more to guys oh I can't
cuz I can't function when I have a sip I
gotta wait over the night time really
yeah right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]